los ésteres son otros derivados del
ácido carboxílicos y si empezamos con un
ácido carboxílicos genérico en la
izquierda podemos transformarlo en un
esther aquí en la derecha no nos
interesaran los mecanismos y las
reacciones en este vídeo no nos tenemos
que preocupar por detalles como si este
oxígeno es en verdad este oxígeno
dependiendo de cómo estés haciendo el
lester en lo que nos enfocaremos es en
como nombrar el esther y entonces
pensemos en cómo hacerlo lo primero que
haces es ver este grupo y reprima el que
está en este oxígeno y nombrar a este
grupo r prima como un grupo al kilo y
luego verás esto y pensarás en el ácido
carboxílicos
aquí en la izquierda para nombrar esta
porción de tueste continuamos haciendo
un ejemplo de acuerdo nombraremos este
esther de aquí abajo nuevamente vemos el
grupo r prima y lo nombramos como un
grupo alquilo ese es un grupo alquilo de
2 carbonos aquí hay un carbono y aquí
hay un segundo carbono y entonces un
grupo alquilo de 2 carbonos sería útil o
continuamos escribiendo eso tendríamos
para empezar luego pensamos en esta
porción de lester cierto
podemos pensar que viene de este ácido
carboxílicos y sabemos que este ácido
carboxílicos llamado ácido acético así
que continuamos escribiendo eso esto de
aquí es
sí no
sí
cómo
y para acabar de nombrar todo nuestro
esther quitaremos la terminación de
nuestro ácido acético vamos a quitar
déjame continuar cambiando el color
vamos a quitar la terminación y ccoo y
la palabra ácido y lo vamos a sustituir
con la terminación ato y también
agregaremos la preposición 'de'
tendremos esta porción
más alto y continuemos utilizando rojo
para eso tenemos esta porción quitamos
la terminación y ccoo y la palabra ácido
agregamos la terminación
acto y la preposición de
por lo que el nombre de este es tercera
acetato de etilo en lugar de acetato de
etilo si hubieras nombrado esto
utilizando la nomenclatura iupac si
hubiera llamado a esto así esto
y está
no pico
lo cual no haría la mayoría de la gente
pero si lo llamamos ácido etam oiko
podemos hacer lo mismo podemos quitar la
terminación y ccoo y la palabra ácido y
agregar la terminación ato y la
preposición 'de' nuevamente aún
tendremos la porción
y no
esto aún será estilo y luego cuando
estamos nombrando el resto quitaremos
esta porción y añadiremos a tu será eta
no a tu otro nombre para esto sería
no
d
estilo dos diferentes maneras de nombrar
este este aunque es más probable que
veas esta forma acetato de etilo es lo
que la mayoría dice continuemos
nombrando otro esther nuevamente nuestra
meta es nombrar este esther en la
derecha y empezamos con el grupo r prima
el grupo r prima es el que está enlazado
a este oxígeno aquí está el grupo r
prima enlazado a este oxígeno y no está
la simetría aquí también tenemos uno y
entonces esta vez tenemos dos grupos de
thilo continuaremos escribiendo
tilo
para empezar a nombrar nuestro estera y
para acabar de nombrar nuestro esther
pensemos en la porción de ácidos
carboxílicos si pensamos en esta porción
de aquí esta fue derivada podrías pensar
que fue derivada de este ácido ty
carboxílicos de aquí el nombre iupac
sería ácido propano dio y ccoo el nombre
común sería ácido malo nico cierto este
sería
ha sido
más
y ccoo
escribamos eso ha sido malo nico y para
acabar de nombrar nuestro esther
recuerda que quitaremos la terminación y
ccoo
y la palabra ácido quitamos todo esto
añadimos la terminación a todo y la
preposición de
esto sería malonato continuamos
escribiendo eso el nombre de esta
molécula este esther sería ma
lo
nada
d
dietilo así bien hagamos otro veamos
otro esther un este muy famoso aquí en
la derecha podría reconocer a esta como
galería continuamos nombrando la
encontremos la parte esther de nuestra
molécula la porción esther de nuestra
molécula está por aquí y empezamos
nombrando el grupo ere prima en este
oxígeno está nuestro grupo de reprima
tiene un carbono por lo que es un grupo
metilo así que continuemos escribiendo
eso tenemos
y flor
y luego pensamos en el ácido
carboxílicos el ácido carboxílicos
correspondiente sería esta porción lo
hemos visto por aquí y sabemos que este
es ácido salicílico cierto continuamos
escribiendo eso este sería
ha sido
y si lee co
del cual hemos hablado en vídeos
anteriores y nuevamente si quieres
acabar de escribir el nombre de tu
western debes de quitar
la palabra ácido y tu terminación y ccoo
y añadir la terminación ato y la
preposición 'de' entonces es salicilato
continuemos escribiendo eso esto sería
salicilato
de metilo el nombre para este este el
cual por supuesto es aceite de cantería
y por supuesto una una de las cosas que
tienen los ésteres muchos esther es
tienen un olor muy agradable es una de
las propiedades de los ésteres y la
cantería es uno de los mejores ésteres y
hay muchos muchos más que puedes hacer
utilizando algo como la esterificación
de fisher bien veamos uno más un esther
más a nombrar veamos como nombrar este
de la derecha nuevamente primero
empezamos con nuestro grupo al kilo
saliendo de este oxígeno y nuevamente
tenemos un grupo metilo así que
nuevamente escribamos mi estilo aquí y
cuando pensamos en nuestra porción de
ácidos carboxílicos esta porción de aquí
quito este ácido carboxílicos en la
izquierda y si tuviéramos que nombrar
eso tenemos un
anillo ciclohexano esta parte sería si
lo sano
y luego tenemos un ácido carboxílicos
saliendo de él sería ácido
ciclo hexano qué
o si el ico
este nombre es algo largo y normalmente
vamos a quitar nuestra terminación
quitaremos la terminación y ccoo y la
palabra ácido y añadiré a todo y la
preposición de el nombre sería
ciclohexano carboxilasa ojalá tengamos
suficiente espacio aquí sería si yo
sal
no
o sí
la
d
metilo veamos si puedo hacer que quepa
ciclohexano carboxilasa de metilo sería
el nombre para nuestro esther finalmente
veamos propiedades físicas de estrés
y aquí tengo algunas moléculas
diferentes cierto veamos a este este
erte aquí si fuéramos a nombrar este
esther tendríamos un grupo alquiló ese
es un grupo metilo tenemos
no
y luego pensamos en la porción de ácidos
carboxílicos qué tipo de ácidos
carboxílicos sería éste
un ácido carboxílicos de 2 carbonos
eso sería ácido acético quitamos la
terminación y añadimos ato y la
preposición de
sería acetato y entonces podemos llamar
a esto así
todo
de metilo comparemos acetato de metilo
con algunas moléculas de tamaños
similares aquí a la izquierda tenemos
dos metí el butano si continuamos
numerando esto
muy rápido
vemos que esto es 2
me tiene
wood
no
y luego aquí a la derecha tenemos
tenemos un alcohol de 4 carbonos
entonces es 12
4 esto sería 2 butanol
comparemos acetato de metilo con estas
dos moléculas en términos de puntos de
ebullición empecemos por aquí con dos
metí el butano
y cuando pensamos en puntos de
ebullición pensamos en fuerzas inter
moleculares las únicas fuerzas inter
moleculares presentes entre esas
moléculas iguales y no polares
2 metil butano es una molécula no polar
las únicas fuerzas presentes son las
fuerzas de dispersión de london las
cuales sabemos son las más débiles y
entonces es lo más sencillo separar
estas dos moléculas el punto de
ebullición de 2000 butano es
aproximadamente 28 grados celsius cuando
pensamos en acetato de metilo tenemos
algo de polaridad aquí este oxígeno es
parcialmente negativo este carbono de
aquí es parcialmente positivo algo como
acetato de metilo siendo un este pequeño
es moderadamente polar tenemos un poco
de polaridad aquí lo mismo para esta
molécula de acetato de metilo y entonces
las fuerzas de atracción inter molecular
entre estas moléculas será dipolo dipolo
sabemos que las fuerzas dipolo dipolo
son mayores que las de dispersión de
london por lo que el punto débil
del acetato de metilo debe ser mayor que
el punto de ebullición de dos metí el
butano el punto de ebullición resulta
ser de aproximadamente 57 grados celsius
toma más energía más calor separar
moléculas de acetato de metilo porque
las fuerzas dipolo dipolos son mayores
finalmente 2 butanol el punto de
ebullición para 2 butanol es de
aproximadamente 99 grados celsius debido
a los enlaces por puentes de hidrógeno
que están presentes por aquí hay enlaces
por puentes de hidrógeno la mayor fuerza
inter molecular por lo que se necesita
incrementar la energía para separar
moléculas de dos butano el acetato de
metilo en términos de punto de
ebullición está entre un arcano de
tamaño similar y un alcohol de tamaño
similar debido a su polaridad en
términos de solubilidad en agua
continuemos y dibuje
y agua aquí tenemos agua
sabemos por supuesto que el agua es una
molécula polar el oxígeno parcialmente
negativo el hidrógeno parcialmente
positivo tenemos una molécula de agua
polar
podría haber algo de enlaces por puente
de hidrógeno aquí entre este oxígeno del
acetato de metilo y el agua podría haber
algo de enlaces por puente de hidrógeno
tenemos una molécula polar y una
molécula polar
así que el acetato de metilo es soluble
en agua pero al incrementar el número de
carbonos que tienes para tu esther
pensemos en este este de aquí aquí
tenemos dos carbonos y luego un carbono
mientras aumentamos nuestro número de
carbonos incrementamos el carácter no
polar de nuestro esther y entonces
disminuimos la solubilidad de nuestro
esther en agua aunque el acetato de
metilo resulta ser soluble en agua
si usas algo como acetato de metilo y
disminuye la solubilidad el acetato de
metilo puede de hecho utilizarse para
extraer moléculas no polares como la
cafeína del agua por supuesto que
mientras más carbonos agregues disminuye
la polaridad haciéndola cada vez más no
polar y disminuye la solubilidad en el
agua aún más